foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
soon enough
time perfect
come on
[Music]
side
okay
[Music]
fans diabet
what time
I'll give you that bro
want to be featured in ochodo TV send in
your Clips by following these steps
before you submit your Clips make sure
the quality of the video is clear put
your IGN as a file name for your video
limit submissions to three to five Clips
a week per category
don't spam submissions and don't send
folders with your Clips on it avoid
full-length matches or just cut the clip
you want on the desired play Until the
End of the round next send your Clips
via Dropbox in the correct category
find it on the description of every
ochodo TV series Once you upload your
video file if it prompts you to give
your name just put in your IGN
also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay match
[Music]
thank you
please understand that it may take some
time for some clips to be featured
because of the review process
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description
[Music]
foreign